so in this movie we see um a group of
middle schoolers put on a play of little
shop of horrors and to just start us off
i'm curious what was your first fear
experience or project or moment in your
life that made you realize
that you wanted to act and do comedy
jenny i'll start with you
i i can't
remember a time when i didn't want to be
an actor i have i i think i just like
saw my very first movie and was like i
want that i just always
wanted to be an actor i grew up on uh
watching we didn't have cable tv in our
house and um there wasn't a video store
in our town growing up um and
um so we got all our movies from the
library and i grew up watching old
movies and wanting to be
you know like like gene kelly and like
old school
movie stars i i just
had a love from the start
i when i was in second grade we did a
school play of james and the giant peach
uh yeah it was fun yeah i got to be
james i was gonna ask yeah which was fun
um
and uh
i don't know i always just sort of
enjoyed either being on stage or
or goofing around with my friends and um
i just uh you know same just
lots of the movies i saw as a kid i just
wanted to
i wanted to live the movies i mean for a
long time i wanted to be a professional
baseball player but i think it's because
i just wanted to be robert redford in
the natural you know i think i just
wanted to live in a fictional world
yeah that i understand as well yeah
um so just shifting to the film
it's all about chaotic relationships um
i really want to know what was the
greatest dating advice that you got or
that you could give to people especially
for somebody coming out of a breakup and
charlie i'll start with you well it's
got to be that you have to
focus on yourself and i think so much of
the pain of a breakup is you're focus
focused on the other person you're
thinking about why don't they want to be
with me why don't they love me but
you really have to love yourself the way
you want that other person to love you
and you have to say okay
charlie you're sad right now but i love
you i got your back
you're gonna be okay and
when you're able to
sort of heal yourself and and take care
of yourself and speak kindly to you the
way you were wishing that partner was
you'll be in a much better
shape to either deal with that
relationship or a future one that may
come up that's very good that'd be my
advice
jenny any advice from you or
uh one thing one of my gal pals said to
me um when i was first dating my husband
was
all of the things that you don't like
about yourself whatever you perceive
that to be if you find yourself trying
to hide that at all go the other way and
try to find a nice way to gently show it
because
um it's just not going to work out if
you think there are parts of you that
don't belong
that's good advice i like very good
advice
um okay so charlie i am very curious
about your upcoming project el tonto
your directorial debut just to shift
gears a little bit i'd love to know when
we'd be able to watch it and enjoy it
and uh what lessons you took from that
experience well that's been a long and
sort of wild experience for me you know
i shot it
at the very end of 2018
and i was about ready to bring it to the
world just before the pandemic hit
and then uh
i had some changes i wanted to make to
it and i had a wonderful conversation
with
guillermo del toro who's been a really
good friend and a mentor
and i was saying look i think there's
some things i didn't get right the title
included
but i could make this better and what do
i do do i release the movie i had a
buyer a studio who wanted to buy it and
guillermo said don't release the movie
make the changes do whatever it takes so
i actually
just recently just at the uh the end of
this year uh 2021
i went back and i shot about 27 new
pages worth of material with ken jong
and myself and uh some with kate beck
and sale and someone adrian brody and i
reworked the film entirely
and i i am now so happy and thrilled
with what this movie is and
it was a really good
long experience in terms of
just
being patient with something and really
soul-searching and listening to your gut
and saying listen if there's something
in you that's saying this isn't what
it's supposed to be
don't release it just because you can
so
i don't know i hopefully uh
i'm i'm just now putting the finishing
touches in the editing room uh with this
wonderful editor um
leslie jones who did a lot of paul
thomas anderson's movies
and um
it's really in great shape i'm so proud
of ken jong who is going to deliver a
performance in this movie i think unlike
anyone's ever seen him do
and um
hopefully i'll have it
in a buyer's hands within the next few
months
and out to the movie at some point out
to the world sorry uh at some point this
year but it's
look i took my time and i reworked it
the way pixar does so i guess i'm the uh
you know the
the stanley kubrick or the pixar of
you know
a lot of people who worked with me are
saying uh
you know if something if someone takes a
really long time on something it's
day-esque now so we'll see i didn't want
to take this long but i'm really happy
that i did
amazing well i really look forward to
seeing it and jenny i am extremely hyped
for daniel quan's everything everywhere
all at once yeah i would love to hear
about your
film in that yeah and if you got any
scenes with the legendary michelle yo
who has been my idol for many years yeah
rightly so michelle is
incredible um i was really really lucky
to be able to i just have a small part
in the film and um the the daniels
daniel scheiner and dan quan asked me to
be in it and um i said yes without even
reading the script um they're so
exceptional and um
yeah they're geniuses i think and uh and
i haven't seen the movie yet in in its
complete form um but it was an excellent
experience and um the actors on it are
sick they're so i'm dying to see that i
can't wait
i mean eventually reading the script
like
it it is um
a super
super original like action-packed film
that at its core has like an incredibly
spiritual message
and the performers i mean especially
michelle her physical work
is
it's it just it's so beautiful
it's she's incredible yeah and i did
have scenes with her yeah and i was um
very very like intimidated and i had a
really good time not by her she was she
her talent is intimidating she herself
lovely woman awesome
that's totally understandable well i
really want to thank you guys for taking
the time to speak with me and talking
about your other projects a little bit
um i really enjoyed this movie again i
died laughing and i hope people will
enjoy it as well uh thanks for the time
and i appreciate it
thank you thanks for your questions
you